well the push to get people vaccinated
from incentives to convenient locations
and now
attention getters thank you for joining
us on this friday at five i'm brian
loftis and i'm denise valdez this one's
really raising some eyebrows brian
getting a lot of national attention
larry flint's hustler club on dean
martin near russell is hosting a pop-up
vaccination clinic today but they're
also offering some free dances and
complimentary bottles for anyone willing
to roll up their sleep
that is where sasha loftus now joins us
live sasha at four
there was actually a line what does it
look like now
brian and denise it is still people are
still filtering in here for this
vaccination clinic it continues for
another few hours and hey this really is
a vagus spin on that vaccination effort
now there are again as i said people
coming in and out it continues through
seven tonight
the club is partnering with the southern
nevada health district to offer
pfizer and johnson and johnson shots
today and those who show up
get to get vaccinated will receive a
package worth 5 thousand dollars
this includes a platinum membership card
free dances from a vaccinated
entertainer
tickets to see the after dark show here
at hustler
those here say this is a great and
unique way to promote the efficacy of
the kovid 19 vaccine
and really encourage everyone to get
their first dose
we just figured it'd be a great fun idea
the vegas spin on
just a fun place to come get the vaccine
we also did it at our hustler club in
new orleans and had
a huge success down there as well so we
thought we'd try it out in vegas and get
some
more people in here vaccinated
this event is available to anyone 21 and
over again pfizer or johnson and johnson
they're giving the two options today
it continues through 7 tonight there was
a line earlier but
it has died down so if you want to come
down here now is the time and those
shots of course are completely free
reporting live tonight sasha loftis
8 news now